Speaker 1: I want to look at one more clip from
this Reawaken America thing. As many of you know.
Donald Trump is not a religious guy. Donald
Trump is not a spiritual guy. Donald Trump has
had out of necessity because he was running
as a Republican to start kind of pretending
to be religious when he wanted to become the
Republican nominee. And so he started saying that
the Bible is his favorite book up there with
the book he wrote, which he didn't even really
write. He had a ghostwriter, but fine with his
own book, The Art of the Deal, and he would try
to tell little anecdotes about two Corinthians and
this type of thing. But when he was asked, like,
What's your favorite Bible verse, he didn't even
have an answer. He said, Well, it's too personal.
I don't even want to talk about it. He now has
found a very spiritual, a spiritual opposition to
abortion, as many of you know. All of this stuff
is completely contrived. There's nothing spiritual
at all about Donald Trump. And quite frankly, I
don't think there is about his kids either. But
Eric Trump in particular has really been playing
up the religious thing. I think it might be
because Eric Trump is kind of the most dimwitted
one. Don jr has his whole thing that he's used
to get attention. Ivanka is less interested in
being in the spotlight and anyway she converted to
Judaism and there's a lot of anti-Semitism on the
right, so it's not like she's going to necessarily
play up her religion. But Eric Trump's
niche has been playing up his religiosity,
playing up his spirituality, and going to events
like the overtly religious Reawaken America tour.
So he spoke over the weekend and he made the
claim that he makes his four year old say the
Pledge of Allegiance every night along with some
prayers. And he mentions in this the anti Antifa
code of destruction, which is not not a text I'm
familiar with. Check this out. If this is real,
it's horrible. And if he's lying, it's horrible
that it's the type of thing that would help
ingratiate him with the audience. Take a look.
Speaker 4: In literally a second week. I'm
there. I've got a little four year old Luke. He
comes home from school and we say prayers every
night together. Right? Right. These little
three kind of family prayers that we say and
the Lord's Prayer to others.
Speaker 1: Okay. Do any of us believe that
every night. Eric Trump and his four year old say
three prayers. Like, I don't know if they do, it's
fine. But I just have a very hard time believing
that. But now we go into the Pledge of Allegiance.
Speaker 4: Just make him stand up, put his hand
on his heart, and do the Pledge of Allegiance.
And so I go, Luke, I'm going to teach you the
Pledge of Allegiance tonight. He goes, Oh, Dad,
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United
States, but he does a whole thing. And I go,
you know, in New York, they would have taught
him the Antifa code of destruction, right?
Speaker 1: Like literally anybody know what that
is, the antifa code of destruction. That that's
not a that's not something I've ever heard of.
Speaker 4: They're not doing the Pledge of
Allegiance in New York that much I can tell you.
But why is it that we have this war on the flag,
red, white and blue? Why is it that we have
this war on the Pledge of Allegiance? Why is
it that you have people tearing down statues of
our historical figures? Why is it the, you know,
like they want to rewrite the governing documents
of this country. They're trying to change history.
They're trying to change some of the greatest.
Speaker 1: He doesn't even know what the hell
he's talking about. So if it's true that he forces
the Pledge of Allegiance on to his four year old
every night, it's horrifying. If it's a lie, it's
horrifying that it's the type of thing he thinks
would convince people in the audience to like him.
And I sort of suspect this isn't really happening.
I'm not really thinking that Donald ever tucked
Eric Trump into bed at night. And it seems to me
like not exactly the type of family that would
really be doing this at night. That's just my
instinct. But it is an absolutely fascinating
family in that sense. I do feel bad for those
kids and the Pledge of Allegiance does feel really
antiquated. I remember when I first moved to the
United States. I think it was in first grade
we were in. I was introduced to the Pledge of
Allegiance and it always struck me as a little bit
weird. And what I always did was I would mouth the
words to look like I was participating,
you know, peer pressure. I was a kid,
but I wouldn't actually say them because it felt
so cringey and creepy and bizarre. And then,
I don't know, I have like I have the memory that
it just kind of stopped. I don't know if it might
have been that in middle school, the Pledge of
Allegiance, instead of being done at the classroom
level, was done like over the loudspeaker where
the whole school would do it, but then it just
faded out. I don't know if it was while I was in
middle school or maybe when I went to high school.
It's not really clear, but it's a strange thing
to be doing in school, and it seems bizarre to be
doing it every night before going to bed. I don't
even believe he's actually doing it. It's worse if
he's doing it, but I don't even believe that he's
actually doing it. Let me know what you think.